hi I'm Lee Silverman and I'm a director
and I'm proud to have been 2014 Tony
nominee for violet and I'm here to talk
about the new excellence in theatre
education award presented by my alma
mater Carnegie Mellon University the
award will be given out of this year's
tony award ceremony on jun 7 i'm excited
about this because we've all been
influenced by someone who truly touched
our lives than teaching and now you can
actually nominate teachers from
kindergarten through 12th grade who
stand out for their own talent and for
inspiring others kind of like Bill
George who is my science teacher and
theatre teacher at Georgetown a high
school in washington DC he inspired me
to pursue my dreams and he's one of the
first people to look at me and say
you're a director so who inspired you go
to Tony Awards calm / educator award to
nominate someone and share your own
story at hashtag nominate one teacher